[Music]
hey guys it's inka
and today i'm gonna be testing out five
famous celebrity ramen recipes to find
out which one
is actually the best and on today's
lineup i've got recipes from plaza
nct's chinla david chang got7s mark
and also kylie jenner i have measured
out all the ingredients exactly as the
recipe stated and because i love
ramen i will also be judging to see
which one is
actually the best ramen recipe i'm super
excited let's get started
first up we have nct's chilla he starts
with cooking the chopped tomatoes first
crushing them with a fork to really make
the soup tomatoey and then he adds a big
heaping tablespoon of laugan machi sauce
he did say you could add more if you
want to so i went ahead and did that
then he adds in the dried vegetables the
seasoning packet and of course
the ramen and then we're pretty much
just cooking the noodles down in the
broth
until it's almost done
that's when we stir in a scrambled egg
stir again
a little more and then we just plate it
up and top it up with what is now a
really flavorful broth
and there you have it chella's ramen
recipe so this one
looks right off the bat kind of spicy
and it smells spicy
and i love the color it's this like
almost like bright red which i guess
could be kind of terrifying but
i love spicy so i'm actually very
excited for this
go for it
yup what i love about this recipe is
that he kind of says that you can add as
much
spice as you want i went pretty
heavy-handed on it i feel like it really
enhances like the original spice packet
flavor this
feels like something i would get at an
actual restaurant
up next we have huasa she starts by
tossing in the dried vegetables and the
ramen letting it cook down until the
noodles have separated
and then she adds in the seasoning
packet and basically lets it cook until
the broth has reduced all the way into a
much thicker sauce that coats the
noodles
beautifully that's when she adds in a
generous amount of truffle oil making
the noodles extra shiny and then she
plates it up
and tops it off with an egg yolk and
then she
mixes it all up before she eats it and
that's it hosa's ramen recipe these
noodles i think
are the ones that look the best out of
the bunch the sauce really clings on to
the noodles
and there's that like beautiful shine
from the truffle oil
i'm very very excited about this one
i love the way hosa kind of cooks this
where she kind of cooks it with the
sauce and lets it like simmer down and
reduce
until it becomes this like gooey thick
sauce
that again coats the noodles and then
you get that added element of the
truffle oil
top it off with you know an egg yolk it
again felt like something that i would
be eating at a restaurant and yeah so i
love that she kind of
made it fancy in her own way i think
this is great next up we have david
chang
he starts by tossing in some butter
olive oil black pepper
and a lot of grated pecorino romano into
a pot of water making it into what he
likes to call
cheesy water and then he adds in the
ramen and basically cooks it in this
cheesy water letting it absorb all that
flavor
he did also say to take out some liquid
if there's too much but we're basically
reducing it into a sauce thick enough
to coat the back of a spoon at that
point he just plates it up nicely and
tops it off with some freshly cracked
pepper
and that's david chang's ramen recipe so
this one
is probably the most different from the
rest
this is almost like an italian take on
ramen if you will as david chang says
even though he also agrees that the
italians probably wouldn't be happy if
they heard him say that but
i love the creative spin he puts on this
i would say this surprisingly works
honestly this opens up so many doors
because that just means we can cook
ramen with
literally any pasta sauce we want like
instead of spaghetti bolognese
maybe it's ramen bolognese i feel like
it could be good i feel like it could be
good i think
this goes to show how versatile that
ramen can be like who knew you could do
it like this
next up we have mark's recipe he starts
by pretty much cooking both the cup
noodles and
the instant rice cakes according to
package instructions which is just
adding in some water the seasoning
packets
before microwaving them until almost
completely cooked
and then once that's done he combines
the two together giving it a good mix to
make sure that the sauce is covering
all of it and then he adds in some mini
sausages
and tops it off with a lot of cheese he
didn't say what cheese but it looked
most like mozzarella so we're going with
that and then he just microwaves that
again for one minute until the
mozzarella just melts completely
and it's done this is mark's ramen
recipe
look at that serve me instant ramen like
this and i would eat it
in a heartbeat this just looks super
indulgent i feel like it's everything i
love in a cup there's sausages there's
ramen there's rice cakes
there's cheese and just smells amazing
this is like the ultimate guilty
pleasure there is literally nothing that
i would not like
about everything in this bowl right now
i think the other thing i love about
this too is that it's literally so easy
it doesn't involve as much cooking as it
is just like putting things together but
i think it is kind of a genius move on
mark's part to
be able to create this dish using just
like convenient store items so
i love this a lot all right so for kylie
jenner's recipe
she starts by adding the ramen and the
seasoning packet into a pot of boiling
water
and cooks it down enough for the noodles
to loosen when that's done she adds in
some butter
some garlic powder and also a scrambled
egg give it a good stir
super straight forward and it's done
there we have kylie jenner's
ramen recipe so this one smells very
garlicky
very like buttery there's almost like
garlic bread vibes from this one
you can see the eggs in it too
i think looks wise this one probably
doesn't get too many points
but the flavor is kind of surprising so
just from that first bite alone i do
feel like these
kind of just feel more like garlic
buttery noodles it could be garlic
buttery pasta
it tastes a lot less like normal ramen
at this point
but it's not bad
[Music]
out of the five celebrity ramen recipes
my
favorite has to be marks to be very
honest
it was such a close tie between marks
and chinless
marks is just so accessible it's so easy
anybody can make it and the flavors just
work together so well
also because every single component in
his recipe
are things that i love so there you have
it mark has the best ramen recipe
there were a lot of really strong
contenders so
let me know which one you think is the
actual winner
i hope you guys enjoyed this and we will
see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you